not very much happened in 2020 bootstrap
5 was released a star disappeared
angular added a new date picker a bunch
of stuff caught on fire
view 3 was finally released beirut
exploded react suspense left us in
suspense
murder hornets r.i.p kobe eddie and kim
spacex used web components while elon
got hacked ufos are real
ufos are real lambda supports containers
while kubernetes drops docker
slack sold out ai learned how to write
code and when donald trump starts his
second term in january i think 2021 will
be an even better year
2020 has been a defining year for tech
they've been big winners and big losers
today we'll look at seven predictions
about tech going into 2021
along with a bunch of events and trends
from 2020 that provide a roadmap for
developers relating to the web
backend mobile ai and more if you're new
here like and subscribe
then let's get right into it the office
is dead
and that's a great thing both for
companies and their employees no commute
better work life balance
live where you want and the list goes on
2020 forced virtually every company to
embrace and implement remote work
big companies like microsoft and
facebook are now permanently allowing
many of their employees to work from
home
this has led to an exodus of people from
silicon valley to more affordable cities
throughout the united states
i happen to be a california refugee
myself and while it's a great place to
visit living there kind of sucks
but the great thing about a global
pandemic is that now you can live
wherever you want
and still bring in a six-figure tech
salary the bad news here though is that
i predict this will make the job market
more competitive
with jobs moving out of the valley you
now have to compete with everyone in the
united states or potentially everyone in
the world for a role
regardless it is still a great time to
learn to code and there's more options
than ever before
if you're self-motivated you can get a
better education here on youtube than
you could sitting through four years of
college and many big companies like
apple and google
no longer require college degrees for
software engineers overall when you take
a step back
the tech industry has fared much better
than virtually every other industry in
this new dystopian normal that we live
in
javascript frameworks are dead well
maybe dead's not the right word
they're done reinventing the wheel or
innovating i should say at least in ways
that will change the current status quo
react has been the dominant framework or
library with the majority of the market
share as long as we pretend jquery
doesn't exist
followed by angular and view fighting
for a distant second place
and a bunch of other good frameworks
like svelt ember and lit element in a
distant third place
i don't expect things to change much in
the future when react released hooks
back in 2019
people acted like it was going to end
world hunger while hooks are great
and they inspired things like views
composition api i think it signaled the
beginning of the end for the javascript
framework wars
there's been a constant push in the
javascript world to create new releases
that do things differently year after
year that's led to the awesome
javascript frameworks we enjoy today but
it does feel like the constant churn is
really slowing down
and that's probably a good thing on a
similar note the javascript language
itself or
ecmascript is pretty much done getting
better at this point
javascript and especially when used with
typescript is an awesome language to
work with by any standard over the last
five years or so
it's experienced a renaissance with a
whole bunch of powerful new features
being added to it but in 2021
things look pretty quiet for javascript
there are a couple of new features
finalized
like logical assignment operators that
allow you to assign a variable if it's
not already defined
also called the mallet operator overall
nothing too game changing and if you use
typescript you can already use the
syntax today
speaking of which and i've been
predicting this for years typescript
will continue to dominate
it's already used by almost everybody
for big complex projects
but i think there will be even more
adoption now that we have deno which is
a brand new javascript runtime that came
out in 2020 that runs typescript
natively
it's an alternative to node.js and i
think we'll see a lot of growth in deno
over the next few years
and another thing i'm excited about is a
new build tool called snowpack
it makes it really fast and easy to
start a project with typescript and your
preferred framework the most exciting
thing for the web though has nothing to
do with javascript which brings me to my
next prediction
web apps and native apps will become
more indistinguishable than ever
and there are two main reasons for this
web assembly and the web platform itself
or a collection of features that we call
progressive web apps webassembly is a
common target
that multiple languages can compile to
which means that you can now build high
performance web applications with
languages other than javascript
on top of that the web platform or
browsers now have most of the features
that used to only be available for
native apps
things like push notifications offline
mode background sync
bluetooth and many more and what this
means as a developer
is that you can deliver a full native
app experience entirely through the free
and open platform known as the web
and that really begs the question of why
are we giving apple or google 30
of our revenue just to use a closed off
marketplace that supports censorship
unfair distribution and bans on
third-party payment systems
everybody knows it's unfair and epic
games went to court with apple in 2020.
it's a long way off but hopefully
developers see the opportunity of
developing progressive web apps with
webassembly
and get consumers comfortable with using
apps outside of the app store
the technology is here today but i think
it'll take multiple years to see any
meaningful change in that direction so
we might as well just move on
artificial intelligence will not take
your job or maybe it will
they took our job by now you've likely
heard of gpt-3
which of course is a generative
pre-trained auto aggressive transformer
language model
it can do all kinds of scary things
including write code this guy on twitter
built an app where you can describe the
layout of a website and it will generate
the actual html css and react code and
now it looks like he's building a whole
startup around this concept
i don't think you have to worry about ai
taking your job and here's why
once ai starts to write code it'll be
able to create its own ai
and that'll be the true inflection point
propelling us to the technological
singularity at which point we'll all
fuse together as one bio digital
organism
or our new digital overlords might
enslave or exterminate us
in either case you don't have to worry
about ai taking your job
what you do have to worry about right
now is something entirely different and
that's the no code
low code revolution which might take
your job
there are a variety of tools out there
now that make it easier for people
without engineering skills to develop
apps
there are tools like webflow for
building websites then amazon has
honeycode and google has app sheet for
building mobile apps
over the last couple years there's been
a ton of venture capital flowing into
low code no code apps
it's a great area to be in if you're a
startup but you might be wondering if
these tools will take your job
my prediction is that they will not if
anything i think they'll make developers
more valuable because they abstract away
some of the most annoying parts of being
a developer for example
you might use a no-code tool to scaffold
out a ui very quickly
instead of taking a week to build a
baseline prototype you now have one in a
few minutes
and you can move on to the more exciting
features that low code tools can't
handle
in fact if you're a developer working on
something repetitive that could be
represented with a drag and drop ui you
probably have a great idea for a startup
in your hands and vcs will throw money
at it without batting an eye
the server is dead long live serverless
which are actually just servers but ones
that you never have to think about or
maintain
the growth of serverless computing has
been accelerating for the last few years
with tools like aws lambda azure
functions and google cloud functions
leading the way
but in the past there are a few reasons
you may have not wanted to use functions
one of which is high latency when they
initially start known as a cold start
but in 2020 we got a new feature from
aws lambda called provisioned
concurrency which ensures you always
have a hot function available
to give you predictable latency but
another big drawback of serverless
is that you can't control the runtime
with a dock or container but just a few
days ago
aws announced that lambda supports
containers and you also have tools like
google cloud run that have supported
serverless containers for a while
the bottom line is that serverless
functions are becoming suitable for more
and more use cases
on top of that we're now starting to see
more serverless databases
like firestore for example or faunadb in
the not so distant future
i think it'll be rare for a developer to
have to think about how they scale or
maintain their backend infrastructure
everything will just magically work in
the cloud similar to how your
electricity works when you plug
something into the wall
it just works unless there's a massive
outage and then you pay your bill based
on what the meter says
at the end of the month it's incredibly
simple and the industry has been
trending this way for a long time
now i wanted to save my worst prediction
for last i believe it's possible we
might see a black swan type event in
2021
just like we did in 2020 with the rona
when the market crashed back in march
it rapidly recovered back to all-time
highs in less than a year the recovery
was led by the tech industry
and driven by stimulus from the
government and money printing from the
federal reserve
tons and tons of tech companies went
public during this period using
s-pacs or special purpose acquisition
companies
meanwhile everybody that's locked up at
home has learned how to become a day
trader which turns out to be pretty easy
when the stock market does nothing but
go up and up and up
all this has contributed to companies
with insane valuations
just look at companies like snowflake
that went public this year 100 billion
dollar market cap on only 400 million in
revenue
and a loss of 350 million and there are
many other stocks just like it
that don't make any money have modest
growth yet their stock prices have
doubled or tripled over the last few
months
this can't go on forever and eventually
there will be some kind of catalyst to
bring everything crashing down
companies that don't make a profit can
only survive with a high stock price
or an infusion of cash from somewhere
else if the market does crash again
there's a very high potential for job
loss in the tech industry
and potentially lost opportunities for
entrepreneurs now don't get me wrong i
hope the party keeps rolling in 2021
my youtube channel depends on it but i'm
just anticipating the eventual hangover
i'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there
you can support the channel by becoming
a pro member at fireship io
or by sponsoring me personally on github
i just wanted to say thank you to
everybody for making 2020 an awesome
year despite all the craziness
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one